[Music]
one thing we find in our work is that
what drives our happiness isn't often
what we think drives our happiness in
one study we gave a set of subjects the
simple task which is go creep
meaningfulness in the next 24 hours and
another set of subjects the simple task
to go create happiness in the next 24
hours and they came back to the lab
afterwards and we asked them the
question are you happy and the
individuals in the second condition the
people that were tasked with creating
happiness said that they were less happy
than those individuals tasked with this
idea of going create meaningfulness and
as you look at how they spent their time
in those 24 hours the two groups of
people didn't really do that much more
differently it was that the individuals
in the meaningfulness group felt much
more connected to people and the world
around them and I think the interesting
implication from this work is that as
you spend time going through the day the
question is how connected are you to
others around you to colleagues to
friends to family members and to even
strangers
[Music]
we asked individuals to define happiness
so to what degree does happiness mean
excitement for example versus
peacefulness and one thing that we found
was people agree that happiness means
excitement versus peacefulness in
different proportions as they age so
what's happening is that individuals at
younger age ranges like 16 17 18 are
more likely to agree with the statement
happiness means excitement and
individuals over 40 50 60 are much more
likely to agree with the statement that
happiness means peacefulness now there's
many exceptions but in general that's
the trend and what we're so interesting
in this line of work was that we gave
our younger individuals or teenagers and
our 20 year-olds a simple manipulation
we asked them to deep breathe deeply
focused on the present for about five
minutes and our subjects that were asked
to do that then were later given a
question which is what is the meaning of
happiness for you and those individuals
who again were very young but then
performed sort of a deep breathing
exercise focused on the present for five
minutes were much more likely after that
to agree with the statement that
happiness means peacefulness so it's
almost like they took on almost a
mindset of an older individual what was
happening for these younger individuals
is that as they thought about being more
present and the breathing focus on the
present it it reoriented the way they
look at life and the way they defined
happiness so what we were showing is
that the meaning of happiness shifts
over the life course but also that the
meaning of happiness can shift even in
five minutes depending on what you do
[Music]